uh in conjunction with the yale center
for business in the environment and the
sustainable sustainability leader series
uh we're thrilled to have uh the
so without further ado mark if you want
to
make the introductions please absolutely
um welcome everybody here this afternoon
it's delightful to have you all here i
hope that you are
enjoying all the burritos and such
things um it was a good start to my
afternoon
um so i am thrilled to be joined here on
the stage this afternoon uh by mark
crumpacker
the chief marketing officer for chipotle
and uh we're also very happy to have had
this interesting link you might remember
if you came here for the alumni panel a
couple weeks back
that one of the folks on stage here was
josh brow
who's a recent graduate here
and he is now working on supply chain
issues in chipotle and he was the one
who i think introduced us to the kind of
reforms that they were doing
and also i think shed some light on just
the sheer scale and potential impact
that these forms could have on the
larger food system
and so our discussion today is going to
really focus around the transformative
potential of some of the things that
chipotle is doing with their supply
chain and at the root of that i think is
an understanding of who chipotle is who
the customers are what things they want
what things they are interested in not
interested in
and that's going to be the rest of our
conversation
so i'm going to be asking mark a couple
questions we'll be chatting through some
of these major issues
and then it's going to be turned over to
you the audience
to bring your questions to the front
and then we will wrap it all up
so without further ado
uh i wanted to say welcome and i have
been completely light on the bio because
i wanted to begin by asking you a bit
about how you ended up in chipotle
because my understanding is you didn't
come from a food background
no i didn't i didn't so
thanks for having me it's good to see
everybody eating chipotle
i hope it's good actually that could set
things off badly if it's not
but
my background is not it's not in the in
the food industry and not in not even
in
in marketing frankly i mean it took me
it took me eight years to get one fine
art undergraduate degree so not an
academic overachiever like you guys are
so my background is in design i'm a i'm
a creative guy and worked in advertising
and design my whole career and had a
number of agencies and one of those
agencies did work for chipotle
we did their
well i did the original identity for
chipotle 20 years ago as a friend as a
favor to a friend to my friend steve who
started it
many many years later um he came back to
my agency or came to my agency and said
could you redo the identity or actually
i complained about it so much the old
one that he'd let me redo it and um that
led one thing led to another and i was
hired on as the
as the chief marketing officer of
chipotle about four years ago
excellent now i think a lot of us know
that there's a new chipotle in new haven
just opened up recently there's rumors
of another one opening up in hampden
and this kind of very expansive growth i
think it's something which is
characterized chipotle
what scale are we at now
like do you know for example about how
many people are eating at chipotle
across the country today and how much
they might be spending at chipotle in uh
this coming year
yeah so so chipotle has about and i
don't know but it's between 1300 and
1400 restaurants there's a new one every
day or every other day somewhere so it's
a little bit hard to keep track so it's
very very fast growing
there's a there'll be about eight
hundred 000 customers at chipotle today
and
we think that's about 30 or 40 million
customers sort of regular customers in
the country so
only scratching the surface i guess if
you look at it compared to the big guys
like mcdonald's or something but
it's about a you know last year i think
our revenue was about 2.8 billion
dollars so it is a definitely a big
fast-growing
company
so that's going to have a tremendous
impact on the whole supply chain at that
scale and so i actually wanted to ask
you a few questions about sourcing
before i get back to the people who are
chipotle
um
one of the themes that we've really been
focusing on here is this idea of scaling
sustainability taking some of these
small scale innovations that have been
very effective and high impact and
asking how can we actually bring them to
the mainstream how can we make them big
now you've done some very interesting
innovations in your supply chain do you
have one in particular where you know
that chipotle's scale was able to make a
big change in farming practice that you
could share with us
yeah well i think the best example
probably is the thing that we sell the
least of frankly is is pork and
i don't know if that's any of what we're
serving today but if you go to chipotle
and have the carnitas you're going to be
eating naturally raised pork and that
that is actually the thing that started
steve on this journey of what we call
food with integrity because
when he had had
several restaurants
he
some of you may know the story but he
actually
got became curious about where his pork
was coming from and visited a uh a
conventional pork
uh
factory and and was so upset by the the
suffering of the animals and the
environmental degradation that he saw
there that he had an epiphany and
decided at that point that he wasn't
going to
allow his success to be based on that
type of exploitation and
from that point on said i don't want to
buy that kind of pork what are the
options and he started
he learned about nyman ranch uh from a
guy named
paul willis who's the ceo of nyman ranch
and bill nyman who's the founder of it
and um
he he learned that there's a better way
to raise pork and and from that moment
on we started trying to buy as much pork
as we could and eventually became all of
our pork and then it went from there
into all these other ingredients but but
the nice thing about pork is that um
we we buy relatively little of it
compared to chicken for example
so there's enough supply for chipotle
but that's only because farmers are
added into the network as our demand
grows the way we calculate it for about
every two
restaurants we open
um
there's a new uh
farmer that can join uh the the network
of these
like nyman ranch uh farmers so when we
started i don't i'm gonna get in trouble
because i remember the exact numbers but
um there were only a handful 30 or 40
farmers in the nyman ranch network now
there's several hundred
and and while chipotle doesn't buy the
whole pig
we're largely responsible for that
growth for these farmers coming in and
we you know we pay a premium for this
for this product um at chipotle our our
food costs are substantially higher than
other fast food brands we spend about 32
to 33
of sales on our ingredients where the
industry average is going to be in the
high 20s and for junk food in the mid to
low 20s
so nyman ranch is one of those clear
success stories where
your position in the marketplace has
really enabled a lot of farmers to adopt
a higher standard of practice
are there any areas that have just been
a big challenge ones where you would
like to see a higher standard of
practice but there's some barrier out
there which is just preventing the
farmers from adopting it yeah everything
else
pretty much i mean but but you know the
the things that we tend to look at a lot
i think because um because there's so
many issues related to them are the way
animals are raised so when we look at
our proteins you know the other things
that we buy of course are beef and
chicken
and
yeah we don't like either of those
frankly you know the our our vision our
long-term vision at chipotle is
is to have all of our proteins come from
animals that are raised on pastures and
that includes the the meats but also all
of the dairies and that's very very
difficult to do in this country our
system is not set up to support that
and so i guess the thing that we're
least happy with i would say is is our
chicken
and when we buy the very best chicken
that you can really get at scale in this
country which is chicken raised without
the use of antibiotics and
you know and fed an all vegetarian diet
but but that's really not good enough
because those chickens are
even those chickens are suffering i mean
if you've ever been seen how any of
these are raised
it's it's not a great story i'm sorry if
you're eating chicken
but but you know the problem is that the
the suffering has been built into the
dna of those chickens now i mean they're
and you guys if you've seen food inc and
i'm guessing if you're in this room you
probably have you know these chickens
have an obesity gene that encourages
them to be hungry all the time and they
grow very very fast faster than their
skeletal structure can can grow and so
it's painful for the chickens and they
often can only take a couple of steps
before they fall down they're not
capable of living out of doors and so um
so yeah we don't like we don't like that
we're doing the best we can and we don't
like it um
so we're you know we're on a quest to
see if we can fix that now and working
on on a new breed of chicken that we
think you know
eventually be the chipotle chicken going
back back and finding heritage breeds
that work better for what we're doing
but to do that at the scale of chipotle
you know with those 800 000 customers a
day it's a lot of chicken yeah and
that's a large undertaking to actually
find the right bird for that many people
are there any other uh goals that you've
got coming up lower hanging fruit that
you want to see as your next big step in
supply chain yeah i mean we're making
some good progress you know i mean on i
mentioned wanting to see a lot of our
ingredients come from animals that are
raised on pastures and we're making
really good strides in that regard with
with dairy
about well all of our sour cream now and
and overall about half of our dairy
comes from cows
that are
um
that graze on pastures and and you guys
again probably being well informed know
this but but cows uh dairy cows are not
raised on pastures in this country
contrary to what we see on the
package labels for dairy products and so
we're we're at about half and more so
probably more what's the number josh
all right 75 percent so
that's why josh is on the marketing team
he keeps all of our messages uh accurate
and um so correct me as i go off track
here josh but um yeah so about 75 we
hope to get there by the end of the year
if that's possible
but you know this is a journey for us
and so once we get there there'll be
something else you know because that
with dairy it started with
buying dairy from cows that are not
raised with the synthetic hormone rbgh
which got us in all sorts of trouble
with the pharmaceutical companies that
were manufacturing it because we were
publicly saying that we didn't want it
and they
were threatening to sue us for just even
saying that um but you know it's illegal
in in the eu and in most most of the
world and so we we set that early on
that we didn't want that and so once we
got there then we moved on to the next
thing and it's it's just an ongoing
journey
so we started some of the conversation
by talking a little bit about the people
who are visiting chipotle those 800 000
people today that might be going to a
restaurant
and part of your job is
knowing what it is that they want and
knowing what drives them what interests
them so i wanted to get back to the who
question maybe framed under
who cares you're doing amazing things
with your supply chain management you've
you're aspiring to a very high standard
how do your customers respond to that
well to varying degrees you know there's
some there's some folks for who for whom
it's very very important and and they
will make the choice to eat a chipotle
because of those things that i've just
been talking about they're a very tiny
fraction of the folks that come to
chipotle most most people
um
all go as far as they don't care
um
and then there's a bunch of folks in the
middle who are do care and and are
interested a lot in where their food
comes from but i'll tell you the the one
thing about chipotle which is true of
any
fast food restaurant or fast casual or
whatever it is
is that this is the way it works it's
taste value convenience those are the
things that matter and they're always
almost always in that order taste trumps
everything
then value
then there's got to be one close by and
these other things that we do like
food with integrity as we call it or or
our responsibly raised ingredients
always come after those three now for a
tiny percentage of people that eats up
but maybe you know maybe it'll get
closer to value because some people you
know equate that with value
you know value can just mean how much it
cost or it can mean what i got for what
i paid too and so it's not completely as
cut and dry as i said but you know
basically if you don't have delicious
food you're out of the game and so i
think the vast majority of our customers
70 percent 80 come
only really because of the way it tastes
you talked about this big middle
category that
kind of care about what you're doing but
with reservations and that those big
three decision making factors trump the
food with integrity but with the food
and with integrity you kind of market
the work that you're doing with animals
the work that you're doing with the
environment uh the work that you're
doing with farmers do any of those
categories resonate a little bit more
with that middle customer base
no it doesn't really work like that so
we've spent a whole bunch of time and
effort trying to segment our our
customers into meaningful groups so that
we could figure out what works with
these guys and what works with these
guys and you know based on demographic
information or or
data you know advertising data mri stuff
you know so
um
you
the problem is you can't do it and and
that's because people's values transcend
these demographic categories and they're
there we found that for example
um you know young kids care a lot about
animals and in particular um
you know as they grow older sometimes
those those change and so it's these
values also morph over time and so so
our marketing's changed it's evolved
over the years it it
it's basically come down to this pretty
simple premise it's this is what this is
how i say it it's basically the for us
the more people care about where their
food comes from the more likely they are
to choose a restaurant like chipotle
and i didn't say choose chipotle i said
a restaurant like chipotle because i
don't think we're the only ones in this
game
but i think the more people care about
where their food comes from the more
they're likely to seek out
chains or companies like chipotle and so
in order to get that to happen
we basically have marketing messages
that are designed to resonate with
different folks you know some of the
stuff we talk about does have to do with
the
the lives and welfare of animals and
some of it has to do with the
the degradation of the environment
around these big industrial farms and
what the alternatives are it might be
about rural farm communities we talk
about that sometimes
a big one we talk about is
is that not all calories are created
equal and that you know a lot of people
are interested in going to chipotle
because they can customize the the menu
if you want to avoid glutens you can do
that if you want to be all you know high
protein and you're a weightlifter you
can do that you know it's it's very
highly customizable and so we often talk
about that so
basically it's
it's a lot of different messages that we
hope resonate with the right folks
with these messages are you actually
trying to change behavior at all and do
you have any success in changing
people's behavior once you get them into
the restaurant
well
you know that's that's um that's my job
is marketing you know ultimately you're
trying to trying to
manipulate somebody's somebody's
behavior in in the world of marketing
and ultimately to get them to buy a
burrito we're doing it a lot of our
marketing is doing it in a very indirect
way we're trying to manipulate their
thinking around higher level issues that
we then hope will translate into buying
a burrito there's another part of our
advertising which just basically
talks directly about buying burritos
it's you know a billboard or a 15 second
radio spot but some of this longer form
content or stuff where we have two-way
conversations with customers is all
about changing their beliefs around
um
things they care about and it does tend
to go into these categories about the
animals the environment health you know
that sort of thing
and so to the extent you can connect
with somebody on at that level yeah you
can change you can change their their
behavior i mean we
we hear this from people you know uh in
our restaurants to say you know i didn't
know you were doing x or y or z but now
that i do it's changed my
view on
on food in general and and the the
reason i know this is true is because
the where i hear it the most is from our
employees
they you know we have 35 000 employees
and i
regularly hear that it has changed the
way their family eats it's changed the
way
their children
you know they
the the lunches they pack for their
children it changes the way their
friends eat
just learning about the stuff that we're
talking about so i know it's if it's
having an effect on our employees it's
having an effect on our customers too
just a question to tie it back to some
of the work which is happening here in
this school
and is capturing i think some of the
academic interests of the students who
are coming through the program is
looking for some kind of objective
measurement of is something sustainable
is it not sustainable how do you
quantify the impacts on the environment
so rather i think than having that
marketing message which is
i think hitting someone emotionally
about the animal welfare talking about a
pig expressing its pigness as joel
salton might say
the quest to actually figure out in the
entire life cycle of that pig uh how
many equivalent uh co2 emissions of
greenhouse gas were emitted um have you
experimented at all with trying to get
like a number in front of the customer
whether it be a calorie count or a
carbon footprint or a food mile
does this resonate at all the idea of
actually giving some objective data
about the impact of the food i mean that
that art marketing typically steers away
from that sort of thing and and so we've
certainly talked about it and thought
about it and and um
you know those are issues or things that
we discuss and and the reason i i don't
think it'll ever end up in our marketing
is is this that we've
our marketing has done a lot of
different things over the years and in
the beginning days it was
billboards and things i just talked
about how big the burritos were
and then it moved into flavor and my
favorite one was a billboard that used
to say
usually when you roll something as good
it's illegal
you know and it went through that phase
of being sort of
you know suggestive and then
and then it evolved into this place
where we were talking about the
protocols you know that
dairy from cows that raised without rbgh
or something would be the headline or
you don't need rbgh to spell dairy or
cheese or something like that you know
that would be the headline and um clever
and all these they were still sort of
funny but but it just didn't work you
know the more specific we got
the less effective it was the more
general we were
and and frankly unfortunately if you
just said
better like ingredients are better it
kind of worked really well
which is
sad
but um
so we're launching our better campaign
next week
there's
there's um
so you know it's tough for us because
you know you know i often say this and
when people ask me about the marketing
challenge of the chipotle and i say that
unfortunately for us we're trying to
solve a problem that people don't know
they have
and the problem that people don't know
they have is that they don't know that
there's a problem with the way food is
raised they don't know how heavily
processed the food their eating is
and so
it's our job i think
uh as
well our job amongst many others to help
people understand that and so our
marketing has become it's turned into
this thing or at least part of the
marketing the stuff that isn't the
billboards and the radio spots the the
deeper more emotional marketing has
turned into this storytelling where
we're trying to explain to people
in an entertaining way without making
them lose their appetite and not ever
want to go to chipotle again you know
that there's that there's something uh
going on out there that they should be a
part of or know about and so so that's
where all of our um more storytelling
marketing has gone and so it's trying to
say okay there's a problem and oh by the
way there's you know there's something
you can do about it which in most cases
is just you know you can eat at chipotle
you know because there's got to be a
marketing message in there somewhere you
know and what tools do you actually use
to figure out what your customer wants
is it
focus group surveys these kind of things
how do you get to know your customer
well with you know one thing that's
somewhat unique about chipotle
or totally unique about chipotle is that
our our menu never changes
so for those of you who've been
long-time customers it's the same thing
it was 20 years ago i mean we added a
salad which was basically
not nothing it was just cutting the
lettuce differently and then saying you
can put it put it down instead of rice
so
so
you know
um our menu the fact that our menu
doesn't uh change means that we don't
really spend a lot of time you know out
there with we don't have a laboratory or
food scientists or anybody trying to
figure out what you know focus groups
trying to figure out what people want in
the next product you know fast food
marketing
um works like this i mean you you
basically have a cycle across a year and
you can have whatever frequency you want
typically it's three
uh or four product introductions every
year and you layer around that
marketing
and you build sales to that to for that
product and then you take that product
away and you add a new one and do that
across the year and if you're a public
company you do that at the same time
every year so that you have comps so
you're not negatively comping against us
a peak from the previous year so you get
into a fixed cycle and there's an
enormous amount of marketing expense
around around that and so of course they
spend a ton of money trying to figure
out what their customers want
so we don't do any of that and as a
result we spend
1.75 percent of our sales on marketing
as opposed to the industry norm which
might be three percent four even five
or if you're red bull fifty percent
apparently
um that's i've actually heard that that
their sales are four billion and their
marketing budget's two billion
um so we get one point seven five
percent so so the research that we do is
really around the effectiveness of what
we've created from a marketing point of
view point of view we spent a lot of
time figuring out if what we did
connected or resonated or what message
left behind
so that's that's the majority of it
so i just wanted to pick up on something
because you had you know talked about
your savings and marketing there
compared with other people in this space
but you would also begin the
conversation by talking about how much
more you're paying for these ingredients
these ingredients with integrity and you
had just mentioned a little bit about
the whole kind of financial context and
the shareholders so
they're they're part of the conversation
as well what do the shareholders think
about these increased increased
ingredients costs and how do you
communicate that
well you know that's a tricky one
because you know i mean if you i think
if you came in and you were
really rich and you just bought chipotle
and took it private and took out all
those ingredients and went you know
saved five six seven eight percent
ingredients and started started buying
commodity stuff
you would have a phenomenally
profitable company we're already the
most profitable restaurant brand of
for the most part of this scale and so
for
you know imagine what you could do and
so i'm sure there's some shareholders
sitting around thinking god if we can
only get those ingredients out of there
we you know we'd be rolling in it but
luckily you know the brand has become
associated with these ingredients it is
what chipotle stands for and it's built
into the dna and the founder is still
the ceo and chairman of the board or
co-ceo uh steve ells and so he keeps it
you know that that is going to be part
of the company and so
the you know the good news is that
we're able to spend more on those
ingredients and still be very very
profitable and the way we do it is
simple it's the couple of things i
mentioned which is the really focused
menu so we don't have to spend a bunch
of time and money
with the scientists and people figuring
out the latest
you know
special taco creations going to be and
we don't have to spend money marketing
that
but also we don't have to spend money
training crews how to serve it or
you know like
re-thermalize it in the restaurant
because if you're going to have a
million different menu items you can't
prepare them like we do you can't
actually cook you have to take that out
and they're gonna have to come
pre-prepared pre-cooked or pre-made and
then you just reheat them like is what
happens in most fast food restaurants so
all the cooking would go would have to
go away
so for us you know these this focus menu
allows us to do just a few things really
really well
and if you've ever been to a busy
chipotle serve a lot of people really
fast
we can serve more than 300 people in an
hour at chipotle which is
vastly more than
than other chains are capable of doing
when you're talking about this
re-thermalization uh i just wanted
to know if you could bring up your
chatting earlier today about one of the
processes to bring a chicken-like
product into a
chipotle-like menu item at some places
around the country uh just as an insight
into uh some of the uh uh twisted path
this follows do you do you want to care
yeah we'll share that process sure you
know i mean so people often ask me you
know what do you you know those sorts of
questions like what do you what keeps
you up at night and not a lot but if but
but you know
our marketing is based on this idea that
our ingredients are better because they
are actually better and i think i've
maybe shared that and there's a lot of
evidence to support that it's true and
it's obvious when you look at our
financials because we're spending more
on it but the risk is anybody can say it
i mean if you're clever enough with your
marketing you just say it right and
that's greenwashing and people do it all
the time and it's becoming more and more
popular and
you know there's there's big chains that
are doing that you know and trying to
simulate chipotle
and um you know they their marketing has
to be very clever you know they they do
they they do television ads where they
show
you know a beautiful kitchen and a
chicken breast on a grill with flames
and beautiful people and ingredients and
at the bottom it said simulated kitchen
not the real deal you know and and then
you're like well okay gosh i guess it's
not that's not what's happening so then
you go to their website to figure out
what's really happening and you you look
at it and it got it's got the recipe for
their new chicken item and it's
it sounds delicious and it's like well
gosh that's just seven or eight really
great
oh it's it's the inspiration for the
recipe it says in
type at the little at the bottom of the
thing you're like well okay well what's
the real recipe then you have to click
onto another website to find the real
recipe which is
40 highly processed ingredients the
primary constituent of which is a
combination of chicken breast meat and
rib meat which have been mechanically
separated to put in a centrifuge turned
into a slurry
reconstituted into a puck frozen
par baked then
painted with stripes that looked like
grill marks sent to the restaurant and
then microwaved and that's that's what
it that's what you got but what we saw
was the beautiful woman in the kitchen
with the chicken and the flames and so
it's like if that's okay then i guess um
you know
i guess so that's the kind of marketing
you want to do that you got to get
comfortable with that but i think that
you know consumers are really really
busy that's one thing we've learned and
they're just they're not going to take
the time to do what i did
you know figure out what was really
going on there they're just going to buy
it at face value so that's a really
really big risk for us you know that
other people will will do this the only
hope i have i guess is that folks
in the end you know of course it'll it
won't taste that good when you do that
so that's a good thing um but hopefully
you know people will eventually
look you know
into the details enough to really figure
out what's going on
you did something unusual in that uh
there was a a big tv spot during the
grammys that caught a lot of people's
attention and i think really told a very
different story than the one that you're
describing uh just now
um for those of you who haven't seen
this grammy's tv spot i think that it
got circulated through the new food
movement networks and was really viewed
as a sign that if chipotle gets this
then the movement has arrived um what
was your consumer response to that and
do you also want to talk a little bit
about the origins of that tv spot sure
well i'll start with the origin of it
which is weird because um
the agency that i had before i went to
chipotle one of our clients was chevron
which we had trouble sort of dealing
with just as an agency like did we want
chevron and we took them
and one of the things i was exposed to
there was their new ad campaign five or
six years ago called human energy you
may have seen it and there was a two and
a half minute
television spot that they had created an
agency in new york named gary bowen
created it and um it would it just made
you cry like you watched this thing and
you thought i thought holy cow it was
like chevron was gonna save the world
and i just wanted to they were babies
and it was just great and
and i thought i watched that and i
thought and then you know a few months
later i ended up chipotle and i said i
want one of those because if they can do
that imagine if there's a story you know
like a really compelling story and so we
started making this film and so that's
where that that came from and you know
we
we
basically told a story which is a true
story of a farmer of ours um
who uh
who is a third generation hog farmer and
whose father had
industrialized the farm while he was a
kid you know it had originally been sort
of a typical hog farm and then his
father said well we gotta
you know the idea here is you make more
money by industrializing we're gonna
turn it into a confinement operation he
did that
the son inherited this thing and then at
some point
he got gored by one of the pigs which is
not uncommon on a hog farm
and in his leg and it got infected
and
he was infected with an antibiotic
resistant strain of of disease that he
had created on that farm and it almost
killed him
you know with months of time or at least
weeks in the hospital and all every
antibiotic known a man he recovered and
at the end he decided um to tear it down
and he exterminated his whole herd and
uh destroyed the the
confinement buildings whatever went back
to
serving a
naturally raised pork and
served sells it to chipotle to this day
so that's where the film came from the
the customer response was
much more than i had anticipated you
know when we created that thing uh we
just put it on youtube and the next
morning there were the phone calls were
coming in and then we
um of people that were
we're seeing it and then we put it in
movie theaters you know plays a little
bit before the film those little
commercials to play and um
people were applauding like we had
researchers in in there and people were
applauding for this thing which is weird
and so
so then we decided to put it on the
grammys you know which was which was a
bold move because you don't buy two and
a half minutes of time on the grammys
and then do something that doesn't
have
sexy shots of the burger flipping or the
you know the burrito rolling or whatever
it is so it was it really shocked people
that we would do such a thing but
um but it's part of that process i
talked about of sort of in engaging
people in this in this
system that they're part of and that
there are different ways of doing things
and
you know when went over really well it
not so much with the industrial food
guys they didn't like it much
at all
in fact there's a there's a new film out
called food patriots you guys may have
seen this or something but there's a
fascinating clip in that film
there's a woman in that film her name's
rodora collins i think and she's hired
by
i don't know what's that farm bureau
some iowa farm bureau or something or
missouri farm bureau maybe and her job
is to go around to high schools and
teach classes of kids
why confinement
farming is a good thing and they
actually use that film back to the start
in the classroom and she goes let me
show you this film you may have seen and
she shows and she goes let me tell you
what's wrong with this you know and she
basically says why this is all all
ridiculous and why you need to put
animals
in factory she goes there's no snow in
that film which there's a whole scene
with the guys dredging through the snow
but she says there's no snow and that's
you know and here in the cold climate
animals don't want to be outside
strangely i guess they all want to be
inside so she uses all these strange
arguments you know and it's fascinating
there's actually people who are paid to
go out and discredit stuff like that
because
the the thing that the industrial food
industry wants to happen the very very
least the thing they're most afraid of
is a swell of public opinion look what
happened to pink slime talk about
changing an industry in a couple of
months like if
if if if consumers all of a sudden get
upset about some particular tactic or
something
that's big big trouble
for these guys so they really don't like
films and marketing like that that
actually gets people
you know emotionally involved
has chipotle heard from any of these
groups directly
in this market oh absolutely yeah yeah
the guy the missouri the head of the
missouri farm bureau guy named blake
hurst wrote an op-ed
piece that was published in the new york
times which i don't remember exactly
what it said it was basically here's why
this is a load of crap and you know we
you know we get all sorts of
you know interaction with our customer
service team and on our facebook page
you know we had
sort of people trying to take over our
facebook page sort of
you know and then they're trying to
paint us as anti-farmer
you know
because because farmers obviously run
even industrial farms it doesn't it's
not really always a matter of scale it's
like there are family farms doing
confinement stuff so family farms isn't
the distinction it's
just there's different ways of doing
stuff and we have a belief that there's
a certain way that we think it's better
that's kind of what it comes down to
i wanted to provide an opportunity for
the questions from the audience that i'm
sure you've got but i just wanted to
finish with one thing because
it's a clarification because of a
question that i got from a student just
yesterday uh it's about the mcdonald's
thing again
so the question that i got from the
student is
isn't it true that mcdonald's is the
owner of chipotle
could you uh fill in the backstory there
um no they're not they're not the owner
you know but there's a bit of
history or truth to the urban legend
which is you know they were an investor
in fact they were the majority investor
um when steve had i don't know a
dozen 20 restaurants or something like
that he was looking for an investor and
he
um went to mcdonald's and they helped
fund the growth from you know to a few
hundred restaurants and and actually
divested all of their interest when the
company went public and never had any
control or well they had control but
they never had much influence or any
influence over the company um
never changed any of the leadership
never changed any of the processes and
stuff so
it was benign but it lives on as sort of
the as the marketing guy's worst
nightmare
really
you know
it's like
so spread the word
i'd like to uh turn it over to questions
so just by hands uh i'll start start
taking them uh
you guys
oh sorry
oh oh yeah is there mike traveling okay
hi i'm justin i'm a third year joint
degree with the school management in
school forestry and
i'm curious
given chipotle's rapid growth um
how you balance the need to continue
growing with the fact that the bigger
you grow the harder it's going to be to
continue to source the quantity of
particularly animal products at the
standards that
you want
yeah it's a it's a it's a good question
i mean the the um
the good news is that in some cases like
the nyman ranch example that i used
we
there's a big incentive for farmers to
join into the network to supply
companies like chipotle
the the problem that we we run into is
where we where we don't use the entire
animal and and with pork it's easy for
us to to sell the rest or for the for
diamond to sell the rest of
the animal that we don't use with
chicken it's harder
you know and so
right now we still have a complete
supply of of chicken rice with
antibiotics but i told you that's still
not even what we would like to see
happen
beef is the biggest challenge for us we
buy all the naturally raised beef we can
in this country and sometimes we run
short and we we have markets that where
we have to go back to conventional beef
and so
um it is a it's an ongoing concern but
our our belief is that our demand for
the higher
margin product for the product where
we're going to pay a premium
is stronger than
than any other force in terms of getting
change to happen economic
incentive is the strongest force we
probably have and so we want to keep the
demand there we're always willing to buy
it so we wouldn't ever let it limit our
growth and we hope that it would
actually incent
farmers to
to supply us meeting our protocols
thanks
uh in in the black and then pink
hello
hi um my name is christopher um you said
before that the more specific you got
with your major advertisements like your
billboards and stuff the less effective
it was
but how do you find that the more
specific you got once you're in store
like i remember the cups used to have
these cute little stories on them about
like the better farms and how effective
they were did you find that being so
specific once the customer was already
in the store was actually sort of like
against your marketing yeah exactly so i
mean the closer somebody gets to the
brand the more specific you can be and
so we um you know it's on a billboard
it's the least specific you can possibly
be probably and so those
those have to be very general messages
but once somebody's actually become a
customer then you can get more specific
and once somebody is a loyal customer
you can be even more specific we hold
these
food and music events called cultivate
festivals around the country and we're
gonna have three this year one in
chicago
one in san francisco one in denver the
one in chicago last year with 30 000
people showed up and it's they're
totally fun you know it's music and
chefs and stuff but we have these this
chipotle experience that you go through
and you get a little passport stamped if
you go to these chipotle things and you
get a free burrito which is a you know
which means
i think 17 000 people did it in chicago
but one of the things we had was a a
gestation crate you know which was one
you know guys you all know what that is
you know where these hogs female hogs
spend their lives in these torture
chambers and we had them
and people could crawl in them and stuff
like that and so we that's very specific
stuff you know but at that point we've
got them they're engaged they love
chipotle they're having a good time they
got a beer they got a burrito and you
know like hey this sucks you know
they're like yeah it really does and
people are really engaged with it
you know so it's it's a matter of when
you do it and but yeah you're absolutely
right the closer they get to the brand
the more specific you can be but at the
high level you
the messages are lost
right next
um what are the companies that you think
are doing
better than you in some areas and like
how are you gonna how are you gonna
respond to that
well
um
that's a good question i've never really
thought about that you know because i
don't spend a lot of time
focused on on the competition but one
thing i can say with pretty with
confidence is that i don't think
anybody's doing better than we are at
our scale
um the size of chipotle and the amount
that we're buying of these things is
phenomenal and it
it the way we're growing we grow so fast
that it's growing
you know each year the fact that we're
able to do this stuff is amazing so i
don't think there's a company of our
size that's doing better there are there
are certainly companies at a smaller
scale that are able to do things that
that i am envious of for example like
serve
grass-fed beef which is very difficult
for us and we're going to get there i
think but it's it's very difficult in
this country
to do that and you know so i basically
applaud anybody that can do anything
better than we are and in the end
if you look at it from my perspective
our marketing is
you know
if if other people do exactly what we do
and actually do it rather than lie about
it if they actually do it then that's a
win right but it ultimately means that
we're not as differentiated
so for us success means chipotle blends
in with everybody else so i kind of hope
that happens i mean i do hope that
happens i do believe though by that time
we'll already be on to the next thing
we'll be pushing the
boundary at the because there's no final
destination in what we're doing here
we'll take a couple more and i should
also let you know that there's going to
be a uh a super special surprise after
we've done the last question um
yes
i'm curious about what you're saying um
with respect to your employees and how
you see them and the behavior change
that they're taking on as an indicator
of your success um with a lot of your
sustainable initiatives and i'm
wondering if you have any uh educational
practices or policies how do your
employees pick up the information about
your food and its quality and
i don't know if there are any lessons
learned there
well the biggest lesson learned there is
it's really hard to keep 35 000
employees informed at a meaningful level
when you know you've got
a turnover of you know around 100 where
so you know a lot of those employees
will leave and then be replaced within a
year it's very typical it's actually low
in the restaurant business really low um
you know but uh
it's a it's an ongoing challenge and
there's there's some misinformation in
our restaurants you know if you ask an
employee well tell me a little bit about
the ingredients oftentimes it's not
right um
and uh they do the best they can but so
so we have a team on my marketing team
we have uh
32 people that are called marketing
strategists and they're spread out all
around the country and one of their jobs
is to teach
not only marketing but the basics of
food with integrity and what we do to
our field teams to the field leadership
and then to the restaurant cruise and
they hold marketing meetings they attend
what they call their patch meetings
which are the groups of restaurants that
perform a patch a marketing patch and
they they basically teach them so we do
it by hand basically we go down and we
we meet with people and we we tell them
and and then a lot of it's spread by
word of mouth from one employee to the
other which is where you get some of the
misinformation it's the game of
telephone and before long all of our
ingredients are organic when only some
of them are you know so that sort of
stuff does happen
anyone over on the south side of the
room i've had my back to you from
peter
hi my name is peter platt i'm second
year school of management i'm a question
about the latino demographic i know
you're mentioning that your own sort of
demographic analysis
wasn't necessarily
that fruitful
in in messaging but i'm wondering how
the rising latino demographic itself as
a category particularly in the southwest
might present some opportunities to for
menu innovation and for new ingredient
sourcing to drive maybe some of the
demand towards grass-fed
yeah i mean we've
in the early years of chipotle we didn't
have much success actually when we put
restaurants in latino communities
which i guess isn't a surprise but of
late we've done a lot of we put a lot of
restaurants in southern california and
in los angeles and and in latino
communities and have done
really well and you know a lot of the
employees at chipotle are latino of
course and so there's a big latino
influence in the company you know in
terms of
sourcing you know we we do have a new
focus on on mexico and some of the
ingredients we're getting there and some
of the peppers that we want to get from
mexico and trying to actually
reinvigorate a dying
type of pepper that we'd like to see
there
and so there's it's definitely been an
ongoing influence in the company you
know with regard to new products i mean
we don't really
add them
you know we we are you know
in terms of doing stuff new stuff you
know we do have a
it's got nothing to do with the latino
community but i'll use it to say that um
we do you know we have another brand
that we've created it's called shop
house southeast asian kitchen there's
only one right now in washington dc soon
to be one in la
and it's basically the asian version of
chipotle and it's it's all the same
ingredients in terms of their
being responsibly raised
and you go down the line and you choose
from all these different things and it's
really delicious it's so
you know there's there's ongoing
influences in the company that may
actually lead to other concepts
hi i'm darcy scheiber knowles also a
second year mba um
if i've heard many people say that if
we're actually going to have an impact
on the sustainability of our food system
we've really got to take a look at meat
and meat consumption and
the quantity that we put on our plates
so i'd love to hear the conversations
that are happening at chipotle and the
inherent tension
of being a kind of meat forward
meat-centric
i'll albeit sustainable
fast food company yeah yeah we do we do
have that conversation all the time
because we're
all of the
the senior folks at chipotle i think is
safe to say are meat reducers i mean i
don't think any of us are vegetarians
but we we think of the meat as a side
portion in our in our meals and it's not
we don't we we always share if we ever
go to a restaurant we always are sharing
the meat portion splitting it um so it's
something that's in our
thinking and
to that end for a couple of years we've
been working on figuring out a a
new vegetarian option
and so we we spent a couple of years
doing this we we had something called
garden blend for a while which is kind
of a soy
it's it's one of those products that's
sort of trying to imitate meat which
which i don't i don't like very much and
steve the founder and the chef doesn't
like it all
this idea of sort of imitating meat and
so so we just created or just finished
creating a new product called sofritas
which you may have heard about
if you watch any of this stuff which is
a which is a organic tofu which
is puffed
which is a nice way of saying fried
but when you fry tofu it doesn't really
absorb the oil because there's a lot of
water in it so it's just it basically
kind of puffs it up then we mix it in
with a sofrito and it basically absorbs
this delicious
chipotle sofrito flavor and we launched
it in seven bay area restaurants a few
weeks ago which admittedly was a soft
target but um
but it's it's gone really really well
and um you know we're selling a lot of
it many much much more of it than we
would to just vegetarians and vegans
which is my objective with the marketing
of it that it's only going to be a
success if we sell it if we get people
to trade off of
meats and we're seeing that we're seeing
first they're trading from chicken and
then second from steak and then third
from pork
into this product at a much higher rate
than we when we would expect if it was
just vegetarians and vegans so
we're going to now roll it out to all of
northern california and i suspect from
the way it's going it it looks like it's
got a good shot of actually being the
thing that we add to the menu so i think
that's a pretty major statement to say
that if you're going to put something
new on the menu the thing it's going to
be is a
is tofu
that's not what the other guys would do
i don't think
so should we should we set up this this
other thing yeah
thank you very much and uh
yeah for the video i just wanted to uh
conclude the form yeah go ahead applause
so let's actually uh conclude the
recording and uh mark do you want to
tell us about sure so this is for your
eyes only this is my test